July 19 Apollo 11 slows down and goes
into orbit around the moon the bright
blue planet of Earth now lies 238,000
miles beyond the lunar horizon
astronauts Armstrong and Aldrin now in
the lunar module separate from the
command module
astronaut Collins remains behind
preparation for the lunar module descent
to the moon now begins
so that moment when the lunar module
separated from the command module
Columbia the lunar module being the
eagle and your two crewmates went off
that that was a tense moment and those
that those hours when they were on the
surface were a period of time when you
really sweated the details tell us a
little bit about what was going through
your mind and your concerns actually the
their separation from me and Columbia
and their descent to the landing was not
what was really foremost on my mind I
thought Neal would do a good job he'd
find a smooth nice place to put Eagle
down what worried me was the return we
we in NASA enjoyed machinery that was
redundant usually they we had to love
something not so in the case of the
ascent engine the engine that would
bring Neil and Buzz from the surface
back up to me coming by 60 miles above
them that that just had one one small
little combustion chamber that had to
work properly or we had two dead men on
the moon and that was I think what was
foremost on my mind I had a long list of
things to worry about but I think that
was number one
you
[Music]